[Música]
todos
no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
[Música]
deja que caiga
deja que caiga la tempestad deja que
fluya
deja que moje tu caminar deja que caiga
deja que caiga la tempestad deja que
fluya
deja que mejor que tu caminar de que
caiga
deja que caiga la tempestad deja que
fluya
deja que moje
salgo a buscar a la suerte la llamo y no
me responde será que viene conmigo habrá
cogido para el monte
deja que caiga deja que caiga la
tempestad deja que fluya
deja que baje aunque arriba esté nublado
nada serio me ha pasado yo estoy vivo
sufridor pero sigo yo soy yo está el más
fuerte a lo malo le hago frente y no voy
a decidir hasta ver al sol salir deja
que caiga deja que caiga la tempestad
deja que fluya
deja que el monje tu caminar deja que
caiga
deja que caiga la tempestad deja que
fluya deja que me mojé tu camino
[Risas]
[Aplausos]
[Música]
wow
[Aplausos]
hola
esto que acabamos de hacer es un
bullerengue de la costa norte colombiana
y lo hicimos sin usar ningún instrumento
todo con la voz y ustedes cantaron
conmigo y eso es lo que yo me dedico a
hacer música colombiana a solo voces
y entonces esos años que he venido
cantando pensé que yo solo hacía música
y no
últimamente me he enterado de que hago
magia
pero todo es gracias a la música vocal
la música vocal tiene magia y es una
magia antigua es una magia que no me
estoy inventando no es nueva
y que hemos venido perdiendo y hoy vengo
a mostrarles todos los beneficios que
tiene la música vocal y el cantar
pero qué es esa magia que es magia magia
es ese encanto ese hechizo que tiene
algo o alguien y ustedes acaban de
sentirlo cuando cantaron juntos y lo que
voy a hacer es simplemente nombrar esos
hechizos
el primer hechizo que tiene la música
vocal es que nos devuelve en el tiempo
nos conecta con nuestro niño interior
este que ven aquí es mi hijo y él me
recordó que uno de chiquitín viene con
las ganas innatas de cantar de imitar de
curiosidad con su voz y todos pasamos
por ahí
para poder hablar tuvimos que imitar y
quiero que recordemos eso como hace un
perro
es tan tímida esta tímida la jauría
a ver cómo hace un perro eso es
diferente como hace una ambulancia
es hermoso ver cómo se conectan con su
niño interior en esa época donde todo
era posible
es eso lo bonito es podernos conectar
con nuestro niño y así es como en
nuestro grupo hacemos para invitar los
instrumentos con la voz entonces por
ejemplo dijimos cómo se hace una casa de
animal
[Música]
cómo se hace una clave
como sea
[Música]
en algún momento nos preguntamos qué
pasaría si hacemos todo el tiempo
será posible y aquí es donde está la
magia
i
y así con esos ojos que ustedes tienen
ahí
se están conectando con su niño interior
con ese momento en sus vidas donde no
había límites donde todo era posible
donde soñar vale la pena
inconscientemente hay algo en su cabeza
está diciendo será que eso que yo creo
que es imposible en mi vida
puede ser posible
y algo está conectando ahí adentro y eso
es magia esa es la magia música vocal
otro hechizo que tiene y que sentimos
cuando cantamos juntos es que nos
conectamos nos conectamos con con los
demás
hacemos parte de algo mucho más grande
que nosotros mismos
y nos devuelven el tiempo también es
como cuando estábamos en nuestros
antepasados en las tribus nos sentábamos
en las hogar en las fogatas a cantar a
bailar
a fortalecer nuestros lazos a crear
comunidad algo que hoy estamos perdiendo
porque llegamos a nuestra casa
vemos una serie de vemos una película
nos conectamos a las redes sociales y se
nos olvidó el contacto directo el estar
con los demás el generar comunidad
y aparte de eso genera disciplina
constancia trabajo en equipo
y el que más me gusta a mí y es que por
un momento
todos nos volvemos iguales a pesar de la
diferencia ese me encanta
ahorita nos sentimos iguales
otro hechizo y otro poder que tiene la
música vocal es que combate el estrés
estos chicos de quienes me siento
absolutamente orgullosos yo los dirijo
ellos son estudiantes egresados
como todo el mundo llegan con problemas
a los ensayos profe
estoy mal en la casa
me peleé con mi jefe me va mal en el
trabajo profe todo se perdió una materia
profe termine con mi pareja
pero aún así van al ensayo
y entran con la cara triste de
cabizbajos pero salen con una alegría
con una sonrisa en el rostro y qué pasó
ahí
eso es lo sintieron cuando uno canta en
grupo una especie hormonas y raras
empiezan a salir por las venas e inhiben
el cortisol que es la hormona que se
agregamos cuando estamos en situaciones
de estrés por eso cuando uno canta
elimina el estrés y miren las caras no
hay estrés
creo que es más estresado soy yo y eso
que estoy sonriendo
con mi tribu que es otro grupo de los
chicos a los que dirijo pero con mi
banda llegamos a canadá y llegamos a
inmigración y la gente nos dijo bueno
esto es que bien hacer aquí no venimos a
cantar ok y los instrumentos no es que
los instrumentos también los hacemos con
la voz la vida gane y empezamos a cantar
5 horas de vuelo sin desayuno sin dormir
cantamos el vallenato más desafinado que
pudimos haber cantado y la gente
inmigración sin entender una palabra de
español
abrió los ojos abrió la boca nos
aplaudía y llamó a los otros agentes de
inmigración y vengan escuchen esto y nos
pedían una canción y otra y otra y otra
cantamos como cuatro canciones y en ese
momento ellos quitaron su etiqueta y se
conectaron con nosotros
dejaron el estrés dejaron todo y se
conectaron con su niño también esa es la
magia la música vocal
otro poder que tiene la música vocal que
ustedes de una u otra manera sintieron
porque hay muchos tímidos por aquí es
que combate la timidez
este está allí soy yo cuando no existían
cámaras de alta definición
de ahí lo pixelado o la pixel
este chico sufría de bullying en el
colegio
no era el más popular y sus pocos
intentos de ser popular eran un fracaso
yo me aprendí una poesía para reclamar a
las madres en el colegio me subí al
escenario todo el colegio reunido
me temblaron las piernas
y su pasión el estómago un nudo en la
garganta el corazón a mil y no dije una
palabra y me bajé
y por mucho tiempo dure con trauma de
hablar ante la gente y fue gracias a la
música vocal a pertenecer a un grupo
vocal que pude superar ese trauma porque
porque con los otros yo saco lo mejor de
mi los demás me empujan a dar lo mejor
de mí y así poco a poco encontré mi
pasión y mi propósito mi propósito es
empoderar a las personas para que saquen
lo mejor de sí mismos a partir de la
música
yo me puedo quedar aquí diciéndoles
marchas más hechizos de los que pudimos
haber sentido pero lo más importante es
lo que se llevan ustedes que sintieron
cuando cantaron con los demás con
desconocidos quizás y cantando una
canción
que no conocían
es lo que quiero que se lleven y tengo
unas invitaciones para ustedes canten
canten mucho cualquier pretexto es
válido para cantar
si están lavando los a canten si están
barriendo canten reúnanse con amigos
canten vayan a karaokes canten pero
canten y a pesar de que ustedes crean
que son malos cantando que son
desafinados o que son a rítmicos la
magia ocurre igual
es indiferente si ustedes son afinados o
no la magia ocurre sus cuerpos reciben
la magia
pertenecen a grupos vocales vayan a
coros canten no sean iglesias pero
canten
vayan a conciertos porque no hay nada
como la música en vivo en vivo es donde
se siente el poder de la música y la
magia está en todo su furor pero en su
efecto si no pueden ir a conciertos pues
escuchen música vocal porque hay una
cantidad de ruiditos que están ahí
sonando que ustedes pueden empezar a
imitar ya despertar la voz que tienen
adentro jueguen con su voz porque están
despertando esa herramienta poderosa que
tienen para sanarse su canto sana y
ustedes lo tienen ahí dormido y hay que
usarlo
como será hermoso este mundo y
proliferarán espacios de expresión
artística como estos donde la gente
pudiera llegar a conectarse con los
demás a soltar el estrés
que nace de vida de energía
a tener razones para hacer mucho más
llevadero su día a día
yo estoy convencido que si cada uno de
ustedes despierta la sensibilidad y la
empatía haríamos un mundo mejor muchas
gracias
[Música]
vivo